ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the studio for the first time believe it
or not on Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
first of many times first of many times
our new friend here he is welcome to
Chris the bagel guy Chris the bagel guy
is here Christopher Morgan Chris the
bagel guy welcome man
how are you sit down joint now you're
amazing
are you kidding me we're all so excited
you like that we're live on the air just
so you know yeah you like that a little
bit you like aggressive music that's a
that's a surprise
[Music]
are you liking your newfound Chris are
you are you a wrestling fan yes yeah put
the headphones on are you a wrestling
fan we you should know I don't know if
you watch the WWE pay-per-view last
night but could somebody somebody play
the clip you can hear in your headphones
right this happened if you look at the
screen right there this was last night
on WWE TV ok and this is for you Chris
these are gonna walk in more aggressive
than a short guy at a bagel shop that's
for you buddy he gave you the reference
on WWE last night you've got it well
welcome to the show Chris it's it's it's
it's I didn't think I'd ever see you
come it's nice to see you just kind of
mellow in the morning well the way this
whole thing transpired I didn't expect
this to happen at all and this is all
real and if everybody thinks any of this
is a hoax it's not it's 100 this stuff
like this has been going on it's been
billing and it's brought this
personality that's why it's real that's
why the people that I work with love me
because they know I'm and natural and
it's coming from my heart because I felt
it I've been through it and it's all
real I have to ask you the most
important thing sorry yeah did I'll ever
give you the money yeah he con man
I I what what happened was I agreed to
give him even though he texted me what
he wanted I ended up giving him like
another $300 and then I he gave me the
rest and I saw a little thing but he
went in and brought out cash but the
fact that he's trying to play it off
like he's broke yeah meanwhile I have
the cash in the house Nicky Santoro yeah
you thought I was way in it you know
it's interesting the way you talk about
your what
what you're doing right now right yes
you're talking about how it comes from
the heart and everybody is so happy
normally these types of speeches that
you're given are reserved for people who
maybe do good deeds or all of a sudden
are doing something
I mean magnificent just doing something
that brings joy to people yeah you you
are actually you become very famous for
yelling profanities at people and and
kind of threatening and getting very
very angry but you're you're treating it
like it's like it's the great joy of
your life I'll tell you what yeah when
you get to a point where so much stuff
happens you just kind of start going
like what the heck part for the example
just pop the match the movie true planes
trains and automobiles love it's a good
one
right remember one is sitting on the
road and also not the car goes on fire
you and I just thought like it was like
that like Brett said I've had it right
and you know it strikes me though
because you've said that but it feels
like you've had many of those moments
this just happens to be the one that
everybody saw yeah and I met like years
ago I used to be a freelance court
reporter I met the guy from Goodfellas
with the Morrie's wigs at a deposition
oh and he goes at the end of the
deposition goes we're gonna make a
Goodfellas tear he goes do to see when
Nikki how am i funny when I did it he
goes to the Lord when he goes he's good
that was a no sex right the guy he was
Mike spoke you met the real Maury yes
well you asked for money like him I want
my money
before the deposition started I was set
my equipment over there's nobody in the
room though he said I might go set up
your stuff and this guy came in with
sunglasses and a snow hat and long story
short he starts talking I didn't even
know it was him and then when I started
here and talking I'm like what he goes
I'm him I'm like get outta ya
you didn't even tell me it fer I have to
ask you to we could we know it seems
like are you you're having trouble with
with the ladies and it's kind of gotten
to a point where you just can't take it
anymore with no way they're treating
nope what are they doing to you and how
are they treating a well I'll tell you
what from speaking to a lot of people I
felt a little better that it's happening
to everybody not just short guys I mean
I have a gazillion stories obviously
it's not enough time for it but most of
them I'm not trying to offend any woman
out of it don't get me wrong it's just
from the heart you know a lot of them
they they come with smiles you know what
yeah and then they promise you this oh I
like you
then you never hear from them again you
know the deal with a lot of them maybe
they're not doing well and and they're
ashamed of it and and they want to you
know try to get over on you and I rather
you be honest and if you're honest and
you're trying I'd be happy to help you
if I'm doing well but to act like that
be sneaky it's like come on I don't I
can't stand Shana's I cannot stand that
anyway and it's just everything and boom
well let's let's walk through the day in
question shall we and you walk in to a
bagel store you want me to just tell you
the whole thing soon I would love that
yeah so I walk in and I've been there
you know I I'm a local fisherman now I
know a lot of people have a fullness
around you're a frequent yeah so so this
one particular time the Indian woman
never helped me
I've seen it averaging about me right
maybe you know like late 50s or
something she had an accent you know and
she I ordered a whole wheat bagel with
two egg whites and American cheese
that's healthy right
well I'm died back so I have to eat that
I so she almost didn't understand the
concept of egg white and I'm like so I
had to tell us three or four times then
she said she understands you this yeah
we need to repeat yourself three or four
times about the egg whites we're getting
a little bit frustrated of course I was
because this happens a lot so um like
write it down you know right most Elie's
do that anyway so then all of a sudden
she walks over to one worker and she's
giggling and then she goes and then she
goes to the Garonne she's cooking she's
looking and so so I let this go about so
after having to tell her three times and
then letting this stuff go um you know
three or four times that sighs excuse me
missus she stopped cooking I says no
she's still coming he says what are you
laughing I what is so funny she stops
he's like now she has this look on her
face like oh he caught me I'm like ha
you couldn't make it more obvious right
so then the next thing you know just
words got louder and because they were
denying it and that pissed me off even
more and then that's when the video took
off so the woman says what makes you the
video starts if I remember right it's
the person filming says something like
what makes you think you can degrade
women what caused her to say you were
degrading women before the video started
when that happened that reminds me of
all the times that if I asked them out I
got reactions like that and it just all
the memories bill thought you started
getting very just pissed off yeah it
brain tapped into something yeah it's
like you feel if a woman gets raped
three times she's not and the Mansa
she's alone jogging in Central Park and
guys to start jogging but he could just
be there
for the purpose of jogging she's gonna
cause from past experiences so that's
just it's the same thing it's just over
her women being raped yeah yeah yes you
know she's not gonna trust any man
anymore
so just started obscure so I have to ask
you because this builds up you said when
you were growing up you you would like
girls you would ask him out and they
would be how would they treat you
unpleasantly why don't get me wrong I've
had girls on or off you know I do a good
amount of girlfriends but they like
today especially with oh I thought the
microphone cut off no I'm like you know
in the old days with the rotary phone
you would have to speak to somebody
today it's so easy to just it's just so
cold I mean it's great because it's
helped us people make money overnight
but at the same time it's it's just
turning people into like forgive me for
saying it but stupid robots yeah we know
frickin personality they blow you off
they blow you off in text yeah they
don't answer even last night one of the
guys that's here in the studio today we
were hanging out he goes do don't worry
this is happened to me a million times
taller better-looking guys I says even
you he goes thought that's just how they
are and I don't I'm not trying to offend
women but I don't get your logic just be
polite and just tell us stop I can't
stand being like the silent treatment we
don't I say a ghost I hate that you said
at one point that women had told you to
kill yourself because you're sure yeah
what is the context of that and what
context did a woman say oh you're I
didn't realize you were five feet or
under you should just kill yourself
this was in all five I was actually at
court reporting school I took a break
and I was on a computer checking my
stuff and I I think I got a message and
I'm sure most I mean I get stalking a
lot of people she didn't remember me so
I sent her a picture okay and then she
has to base a pedigree information when
I told that some said are you serious
you should kill yourself your family
should you should be dead and I was I
still remember that and that was an old
fear and I'll never forget that and I
even show one of my teachers the email
so you in the deli
waiting for your bagels you got mad at
the woman filming you because you
remembered in 2004-2005 I had no
problems with her filling me you know I
didn't care about that no I mean you
were mad you you directed your anger
towards the woman filming you like hi
she's a young kid and he hasn't lived
half my life and you're questioning my
validity
she doesn't understand where this is
coming from like listen I was in college
when you weren't even a thoughts be
quiet I see yes
yeah nothing the registration builds up
of course it does I'm not a bad guy but
when you put listen you're gonna go to a
zoo get a stick and you keep poking a
lion and see what happens
see what happens I gotta fit yeah we're
gonna get bit
damn why there was one thing to where
you said that guys that who tackled you
is three times your size yeah
one thing that struck me though is you
you did what a tough guy right frog
could for you yeah I didn't like that he
did that either you - aw sorry I didn't
either
you did kind of chest bump the one guy
though like you did I did yes yes
because I need a little fizz my dish I
think cuz I was already heated and I'm
talking to people burning in my business
but the the what I could have forgotten
forgiven all that the thing that sent me
over the edge was when he had me he had
his knee on my back I couldn't get him
off me and he had my shirt PO I was
starting to like slowly suffocating you
did have your shirt pulled over your
head he had any wooden ties that yeah
yeah and I couldn't almost breathe after
a while but let me ask you know so how
much of it is personal responsibility
when you say to a man who's three times
your size two times your size everybody
I met I know you say to him then come
and attack me and then he responds in
kind by saying I will accept your
invitation and I will thank you meaning
like like prove your tough-guy by
beating someone up my size that's
basically what it was meant for
so it was understanding right if it was
a Minnesota saying that's where that's
what I meant by it like come on like
you're like oh you're gonna prove you're
bad but you know that's what it was well
you're angry guy you can see have an
angry or a good dude that's cool my
friends I have a gazillion friends well
where's Romeo did you bring him well I
tried reaching him we enjoyed your video
of Romeo making you laugh with the the
Ernie doll you really oh no no that's it
that's Jose
oh that's Jose cause every guy you saw
we watched you kid me I watched right
that's one of my many normal friends and
I fish with I know but you don't good
well you can't say oh my god of
satellite
Ricky you never them [ __ ] a
juggie don't give a [ __ ]
shoutouts all you guys at the marina
I'll never forget all you guys you know
I mean I can't run that Alissa's too
many people you are named exactly um so
but you don't consider yourself an angry
guy cuz when I looked at this I said but
all the time like a Charles no I've
never seen the reason I think that this
went so incredibly viral and millions
and millions and millions of people have
seen this I mean you know we I tell you
how popular this video is I've heard Jim
and I watch the video on the air and
just kind of did a breakdown of it yeah
the video of us doing the breakdown has
almost a hundred thousand hits on it
it's and that's us just doing the
breakdown just discuss the stagger but I
think part of the reason that everybody
is so interested in this is because it's
late at some weight like if you have a
handicapped brother they can relate no
you are incorrect I think that the
reason that they're really that they're
so interested in this is that they have
never been in a situation where they've
seen anybody get this angry for
apparently no reason I think that your
behavior might be a little less common
than you think
yeah but as I said there's a whole story
behind for every action there's a
reaction right so now if I had a decent
life and I was like that for no reason
you'd be like okay there's a problem but
you you see no I have for my stuff on
YouTube a lot of employed people yeah
and people trying to bezel money enemy
you call me a partner it's like who do
you trust anymore I say you get like
sometimes you get whacked at you a math
mistake with al by the way it's been
driving me crazy what you value owed you
1,500 bucks yeah you said - al
all right 350 300 I'll give you 500 but
then you took the 500 out you had - 300
made at 1200 and then you go I'll just
get I'll take 500 off you owe me 700 is
your cell phone yeah three bucks I
realized and I was so angry I yeah
you're right but you know right it was
like Dubai you bring an account but he's
but here's the kicker a week before this
happened right we went to Jake's casino
I don't know okay fifty-eight he wins
five hundred bucks
so I'm waiting for him now he owes me
1,500 bucks and I'm like yeah imma give
me 20 bucks he didn't even offer to
start to pay me back so that was just
such a slap in my face so you don't send
flat you're friends with am I still
fresh you didn't went back after that I
don't think I'm gonna go back I don't in
prison I'll tell you that you can if you
want to say [ __ ] instead of crap you can
okay yeah but I don't know if you
noticed in that video if you scroll down
there's a comment down they have a guy
that knew him anyway he would he had a
company he would demolish their homes
take that deposit leave their homes
correct they eventually found out they
raided his office closed it down they
took all of his laptops and shut him
down real and I never knew this about
him but you kind of saw it coming when
you had that interaction with him I know
I used to work for me on the restaurant
and he even own a pizzeria Ronkonkoma
but he I know for about six seven years
and and then this just started brewing
like the last two three weeks it was
getting Skippy you know and sketchy and
um and he never really came across as
that ever right do you have a girlfriend
now because we know so I got you you get
some honey I got some phone numbers in
my metal I never you know pictures but
actually dating no I'm not with enemy
currently I trust me when you got this
kind of Fame dating anybody exclusively
is not the move I mean get out there and
play the field a little bit that's what
I mean you know how to play the game at
this point so and you know one who but
but there's so much cheating going on
when people get I have a close friend of
mine one of the guys at the marina and
he liked this girl and I trust it and he
basically found out that I'm not gonna
mention names but diga and she and they
known each other for a while and she
buttered him up with great great
comments and he and he's about maybe
five eleven six feet and he walked in a
barn and basically heard or something I
forgot the exact story that she was
cheating on him it's like home I got so
another example of why are you gonna
waste your time saying you like this guy
this is what I'm so you can't trust
anybody anymore have you been cheated on
have I yeah if I have I've never known
about you no record about it I know and
I've never heard about it or nothing but
you don't trust women
you know let me tell you something I
found that from talking on dating sites
with plenty women for years and again no
I'm not trying to bash anybody here but
this is from experience that you know
you don't question your teacher who's a
lawyer who's been in school for seven
years and worked in firms you don't do
that so you're not gonna question me on
this I have experience with all due
respect everybody you're gonna respect
this when I say this no I don't I don't
respect them because I've again they
they just lie right most of them lie
right through their face but I found
that once they start to get over like
forty to fifty and even some of them are
still whacked but you can I find that
you can actually have a normal
conversation and not worry about that
[ __ ] because they're getting more mature
once you get menopause out of the way
you can actually start talking to these
people I know so you are you consider
yourself having a legal degree in the
ladies at first I would speak at first I
didn't even have a certificate now yeah
you have a Doctorate degree kind of girl
you're looking for
well if you could have a girl right now
that you could date steady and go out
with what are you looking for any what
kind of girl um I mean hi really doesn't
matter but I prefer something you know I
mean that my ex was wife was five four
I've dated five seven but I mean it and
nothing not too too tall but it doesn't
but I'm really not limiting myself but
she's my favorite is tan skin with like
black hair and if they have like a pink
bikini with black polka dots if it's
over oh so you wanna oh so you want you
want a black girl or a Latin girl you're
saying Tarot Weicker
oh you know I'm not ready I'll take
anybody I'm attracted to if I'm
attracted to your face you're in but my
favorite is like like like Mexican Scot
Mexican calm Emma selena quintanilla
Selena how old a girl do you want do you
have a preference for you no no but I
mean as long as you if you find the
right because age is just the number as
we know but if you find one that listen
I've met Groza with 24 more mature than
40 year olds and vice where it's just
sick right they're all different it's
incredible but that's good that's the
way God made it you don't walk into an
ice cream parlor and they will have all
mint chocolate chip I heard no I heard
that
so in high school you said you
you got picked out of people treating
shitty so not too too bad not bad
I heard although I heard and this is
just as high school in that it got worse
did they call you Alf in high school
yeah yeah only a couple of guy I kind of
caused that I'm not gonna get into the
story but he did it in reactionist I'm
not gonna get into it why did he call
you out yo I don't understand either he
did you know he no he didn't and then
one of my friends that knew him said oh
we called you up but I was like oh no
I'm not gonna get into the story how
come did I hurt your feelings now so
small though that was kind of funny too
okay you seem like a rational nice dude
of course I am I'm college-educated what
the [ __ ] would not yeah but anyways
right there that's very funny you seem
like a nice guy what the [ __ ] said I'm
not but do you you're a [ __ ] Fugazi it
depends on the day it depends on the day
it also depends on how high I get to
were you like to do drugs
mmm yeah what's that you do drugs just
marry and that calms you mix makes me oh
yeah an edifice to your personality
remember what Bill Cosby goes but what
if you're an [ __ ] Bill Cosby still
smokin actually makes more angry no I
wouldn't say that
okay melis yeah yeah I mean I've gotten
angry when when I was young when I never
even started doing it that's the same
[ __ ] if you triggered it it happens hey
whatever happened to the the the the
guys at 7-eleven I watched that video
too and you walked they're huge just to
give a quick rundown on how that
happened because that was outrageous
tonight can I just tell you what led up
to that point yes all right so I was I
was living in an apartment in Medford
and they put me through hell and I was
so nice and wait wait I'm not gonna get
that we know I'm enough time anybody up
they were three yeah so there were three
cops a we were talking to male and a
female cop so the female cop goes why
should i we want life and it's I'm gonna
say it you told me I could say yes this
is what I wanted a lot of [ __ ] money
and the hottest [ __ ] women and she
goes like this okay
right but it's good sale goals yeah
that's my goal Merson yeah so I moved
out of there
then I found the department in playing
you when it turns out the guy was my
high school I wasn't the high school
with him he lived around a block from my
parents we played football in the street
there was a whole big thing when him and
his family didn't get along he didn't
pay the mortgage on the house two weeks
later it turns out that they some new
people bought the house and I just moved
in there
I bought a $4,000 van which turned out
to be junk underneath they did with the
steering was all rusted out when it was
time to do the inspection four months
later so I lost four thousand on that
right and then before I left that
apartment everything was going on with
one we should leave then we set a time
and then they're changing it then the
guy was gonna skip out early and the
lights went out there and then the and
I'm on the road going to a cleaning job
and he goes did you hear something pop
last night says no he goes well your
whole basement is flooded so then he's
the Sun and he wants to skip out leave
me with no lights no heat and my
basement flooded with a bird down there
so my father had to come because the guy
was getting sneak and he wanted to bail
out we both went on the door the night
before me a bird is probably the last
animal it's got to worry about a flood
that is know that's like my kid I love
him he's I know what I'm saying birds
can go high oh yeah
and he basically the night before we
moved out we we we audiotape in and he's
like we were all in with him on the
steps right and and he the next day he
gave me $250 to you know the help hour
for a while
righteous and then I moved to a
beautiful place a beautiful apartment
out in Miller Place not gonna mention
names or addresses and I think
everything for this person and just know
and and and I know the backstab thing
and every shell money out to help pick
stuff up for this person and you were
generous and giving and we talked to you
again yeah I shoveled the driving when
it's snowed in was a bit I lived on
three acres do you think a mistake your
kindness for weakness I think that's
what's happening yeah and then and then
the funny thing is when you catch them
on and you get mad they like like
reverse psychology but that's just and
that's just a that's just a way of oh
[ __ ] I'm wrong I'm embarrassed and so
they want to push the blame you know
[ __ ] happens or spa I like Chris when
you call them out on it on their descent
embarrassed yeah yeah yeah and then you
play reverse psychology [ __ ] you know
you know how to put up with that [ __ ] no
I'm done with that [ __ ] I'm - all I've
learned you you know I've studied I know
you know you can't fool me anymore
can idiot Mary Mary don't I was yeah
that was my fault
yeah oh really most of it was my fault I
was having trouble holding jobs and my
anger was worse and worse than now well
yeah because I'm not gonna get into why
there were other reasons why but she was
a wonderful woman and I screwed that up
but I bumped into her six easy answer I
was giving out my flyers for my cleaning
company and she was seemed happy to see
me she's reengaged and I I said I'm so
grateful to God I want to tell you this
opportunity Isis you know I said you
know it was it was mostly me don't take
the blame and and she says I don't worry
about and I just know III it's important
for me to tell you and when I left that
day I started crying because I was like
I was so thankful had the opportunity to
get that closure on it you know a guy oh
yeah yeah yeah I'm a cancer yeah me too
you kind of made amends to her and said
and she obviously must have made it
before me because she I love she was
totally acting she you know when when
she when she left before we got legally
divorced on paper we had $15,000 cash in
the box and I offered to shouldn't take
a nickel and possibly because is my dad
gave her Alexis too you know to help get
around so that's probably Alexis before
the yeah but honest to god shouldn't
take a nickel so have you had trouble
replacing her oh yeah she was not from
this country that's why was she kind of
the runaway say again but she like the
one who got away yeah I don't want to
embarrass the person but there were
parts of me that were not becoming
attracted to her because she she didn't
have my taste went from girls with big
trusts to not and then it started to go
back and I just it was horrible I felt
bad and she wasn't very much yeah she
that she got mad at that I don't blame
her you know but I had to be honest with
don't walk away oh man so when you got
married you were attracted to girls with
smaller chest yeah yeah what happened
then you evolved into a man who liked to
bust your girl I I started watching
James Bond movies and most of this stuff
was shot in the Asian culture and I had
a big what Great Wall of China beautiful
tonight
great Walt frame where lights on I'm
like I want to see this culture yeah and
but I wanted to meet someone first so I
didn't want to go alone because I was
scared [ __ ] and I was talking like 30
women over there and Philippines and
then eventually got an arrow down to two
where'd you meet him online or on
name that tickle calm that's what it was
years ago take hold calm yeah it was
years ago and then so I flew over there
and she was a great go I was there for
three weeks the country was beautiful
but she lived almost on the equator it
was I'm when I tell he was [ __ ] hot
right ha sure
and but every dollar you spend is like
ten dollars worth there but so you meet
this this wonderful person on tickle and
you go and you spend some time with her
in China know Indonesia Indonesia yeah
okay apologies and then what do you
bring her back
yo later she came over ah and then the
government only gives you three months
to get married show how did you tell you
said that you felt bad because you liked
bigger breasts you start to like bigger
breasts and they were small right how
did you tell her like how did you say
like look these are not working for me
yeah you know what to be honest but you
said you felt bad you know what even if
I did remember I'm not gonna say but I
honestly don't remember but I just do
remember saying in a way that you know
I'm gonna do your girl we should go oooo
I you know what I kind of said like you
know fixer so will you pay for you know
I was like you wanted her to get
implants yeah oh you said that and she
said you shaved work I mean she kind of
took it pretty good but I know that must
have pissed her off cuz she came all the
way over and I don't blame him I [ __ ]
up I told her right fright you bring her
to America
she thinks she's good the way she is and
then you dress she was a beautiful girl
as you get implants beautiful girl but
your tastes changed it's just like this
look yeah I have all the good qualities
this that and I would try to sell myself
but the women would take because the one
thing in the height so she had all the
good qualities and to me you know what
and and and I don't mean it towards my
ex-wife at all but now after what these
women is owed to me you know I have a
preference but sadly with her right it
was like how do you have one thing just
destroyed if I mean in the beginning I
feel like you did like you do the same
thing to her that people do to you like
there's a physical thing but it wasn't
it maliciously no no no no right like
you looked at something like wow I
shouldn't have kind of judged her on her
it began and she picked up on and it
began to be like oh I think you just
love me like a sister like I kiss her on
a forehead instead of many ways because
of the breasts it was and then what
happened was she would go to she would
work and go to school to nursing at
night and then she'd work and do
homework on the weekend and she was and
so the amount of times we had sex would
go down and then reverse what's our
choice or hers kind of know
more horrors and I didn't blame because
she was exhausted right and and I didn't
want to you know like boga because I
didn't blame her but I was like what am
I gonna do you know I'm but at the same
time you weren't a sexually attracted to
her anymore because of no I was there
but the only thing was that but yeah but
then it was like we didn't we didn't
have similar interests and that's why
chemistry is so important that's what
I'm trying to tell the world this is the
message to get over the height in the
superficial [ __ ] because it helps put it
in the rests well it helps to be
attracted to a person in the beginning
but in the long haul if you want to be
with somebody right you gotta have
chemistry no you're not gonna be with
each other so what's the [ __ ] point
so was the divorce your idea are you
saying like well I I try to save it with
with counseling and she know she was she
got hurt you hurt her to a certain point
and listen we look you can't say it's on
you know absolutely that's what they say
you like what you like yeah right and it
was really nothing meant maliciously and
like you know and do you regret the way
it went down there like the way the but
you regret out of the way yeah I know I
mean we had great times too you know
about it should happen and it's been
hard to find that second person who
makes you feel that what kind of
especially when women are telling him to
kill himself yes right right I mean I
mean I don't remember who was I was
talking to in the last day or two but
they're like just most of the women here
are trashy and garbage and I'm not
trying to disrespect this is somebody
else telling me this yes really and and
obviously there's tons and tons and tons
of gorgeous women here but to find your
perfect match who's not a [ __ ] over
it's it's really I had a woman tell it's
very hard to find your exact you do you
think I married women our bitchier than
women in other countries and I've heard
you know when you get out of I had
someone telling me like if you go to
Pennsylvania you just have a job in a
car you're having sex right here it's
like you need a Ferrari a mansion yes
disgusting right so yeah and it's still
miserable do you look now do you like
girls who are taller like you know I
prefer around my high but I'm not gonna
I mean it's they're way too tall like
I'll take like up to here or if I'm up
to here like no more than that you know
you'll hear up you as long as you're I
would do their show six inches yeah I
was like no more than and then I start
to feel really insecure but you know
what's weird sometimes depending on the
girl especially if I get along with her
if she's taught a little taller
I feel more comfortable where her than a
girl my I don't know why it's weird have
you been back many ways no they invited
me back twice it's good for business
yeah I was like I want to let the stuff
[ __ ] black will you go back there I
don't know you know what I'm gonna talk
to you know my manager about that
because if it's obviously something good
then maybe we'll do your entertainment
manager do you or your manager at work
or give an entertainment manager you
know him
so can I mention his name yeah Anthony
all right I mean I before I met him
obviously I'm like I'm not [ __ ] going
back yeah omegas is herself to have me
arrested for trespassing [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and people told me don't go there but if
he wants to call them and I know I have
a crew there then I'm safe yeah I'll do
it
so you you know what I thought was
really interesting about you what I like
about you is that a lot of people deli
all I am trying to teach people like
there's like even we were ball happen
recently there's so many gorgeous women
and they look miserable look at me
this is not when I wasn't this is all
this happened now right okay and my
cleaning company wasn't is not doing too
well it's okay but the hydration yeah oh
and it's licensed and everything but um
so anytime that I was not working I
would be at the marine with all my wacko
friends fishing and getting tips you
know I live like this every day because
I love that
and you never know cause it's a party
the reason I forgot to tell you this the
reason that I've
so this mindset is I had a guy a friend
down a who collapsed right in front of
me dehydration and I thought he was
having a heart attack
and it was at that and I almost died
twice this year because I was [ __ ]
with my health and then when I saw that
he went on boom and his and his hat fell
and I know the guy whose hat fell yeah
we've had to call the paramedics and so
the one I might get his hat back on so I
guess that his sugar was on I told pare
America's check his sugar was 211 so
then we had gotten him up but he was
shaken he could hear us right but he
couldn't talk back to us well I was very
scared but anyway the gist of this is
this the moral is when I saw that happen
I'm like you can go anytime I'm like
[ __ ] this I'm gonna whatever I want I'm
taking it right now so if you like a
person now it's too early to text stop
these mind games if you'll just go
because you could be dead tomorrow that
relates to that brings me back to my
where's the time right that's what I was
gonna ask you about that most people
they get this this viral fame and they
try to get away from it they go oh my
god I'm so humiliated they panicked
panting they go I don't want people I
look so terrible in this video I'm
they're showing me in a negative light
you leaned all the way in you started
doing interviews you started reaching
out to people you're here in the studio
you're saying and not only are you
defending your behavior you're saying
[ __ ] yeah anybody that no one's gonna
[ __ ] change it ever right anybody
that thinks I'm the problem why don't
you take a look at the other people in
this video why don't you take a look at
why right I'm the way that I said you
nobody heard my date away with that
would they they claimed that I'm not
they said that their man beat them up
and I'm like why
right boy I'm gonna get their side of
the story it wasn't for no reason
problem don't get me wrong I mean if you
didn't know a guy needs a whack on a
drunk man's in a bed but every one of my
ex landlord said her husband put a
[ __ ] head through the sheetrock Jesus
[ __ ] did you do
why did you tell me that right why did
you say what did she do to me we got
along really well I liked her a lot but
I don't like it like hello nobody does
that you're saying that a lot of women
that are victims of spousal abuse it's
like well it's a two-way street honey of
course it is right yeah
I wanted to ask you to cuz I watched
your news 12 interview I went on a real
Chris loop and uh it's a good interview
yeah it was very good was actually in
depth and they didn't just ask you a
soundbite question and you said that it
for people who I guess are shorter
victimized you're like they're Martin
Luther King jr. right you say yeah but
the whole black thing it's the same I
have a lot of black friends so I relate
you said you're the enemy that's why I
relate these [ __ ] people I see do you
say and like the power that be right
Public Enemy your favorite song by then
that's prime mine oh yeah man it's like
[ __ ] we taking a [ __ ] no more when
you're getting to I was gonna ask when
you're singing along talk to you that's
right you know when you're singing along
to Public Enemy you talk to me like that
right exactly I mean they come see you
and in comedy 8 me rock you you're not
God or my boss or my father right [ __ ]
you
and they come at you like you're the
crazy one yeah like their God are you
flawless like yeah that's what I'm
saying and not only that do they think
they're flawless but like this don't
even involve you this conversation who
the [ __ ] do you think you oughta get
involved so in business so you're damn
right you you have a good relationship
with your dad cuz you mentioned your dad
so obviously he's a guy that you use you
that's the living yeah they're both
alive okay so you have a good
relationship with I mean we could we we
kinda had a bad fight a few weeks ago
but I mean they've been very very good
to me was that on you or him the fight I
don't wanna get into details but but
they've been this is what oh and I
literally said someday that that this is
gonna happen to Fame cuz I want to take
care of them would have put a surprise
gift and I might have him I can't say
that I'm surprised if he says it yes
listening well you don't know that so we
can hear and tell them just whisper yeah
what and they deserve it to where they
are monetarily will to help them at the
end you know they deserve I think they I
think I like that you're paying it
forward I think that it's important you
know I mean once the it comes in where I
can't pay for it I'm doing hey when
you're singing along with Public Enemy
will you use the n-word with the AIDS no
no never you drop it like what it unless
not touch that somebody I can't do that
I don't want to find anybody call her or
anything like that so
if you're singing along with the song if
it's if it's understood that it's just
for comical reasons of course okay but
yeah that holy I don't wanna get the
[ __ ] kicked out of me right no no people
walking down through walls through a
home on myself I did you see a video
right you gonna see me no more that make
sense people responded to you pretty
much people have been I mean generally
since after the video yeah let me tell
you something this is the latest update
on your question I was hanging out last
night in the back seat of my friend's
car and talking about business and he
was holding up his office well yeah no
no [ __ ] it was a radio show so he's
holding his phone up and I see and my
eyes aren't too good I got diabetes you
know it's a little blurry so I see all
these little bubbles and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is that he goes these are all
your fantasies or hearts from when I'm
and I was like you dropped your Snapple
right there it was like a torrential
rain of [ __ ] range of of hearts
pulling that I'm pouring down on a cell
phone how many of those women need a
good trust
yeah a lot of people said you know I
think could just be a collision
and I get it you know but there might be
some good ones out there but it's just
the fact that they were exploding like
that whatever the optimist
everything yeah I can believe it are you
gonna use this opportunity think maybe
meet a nice girl like you know cuz now
it's easier when they know who you are
they'll give you today yeah if we want
to go on a date if you could take a girl
you not pick you won't listen I can name
one Dahlia bucko - that's right yeah we
should a bagel shop Sedalia where Romeo
was dancing that was fun I get confused
I mean it's an alley
Romeo dances in the deli so he was gonna
take that girl for way from him
oh yeah no but she's smacking like hey
like that he should weep Romeo datings
they didn't stay long if you noticed
like they left after that cuz he he was
cooling him but he was gonna he's like
he's gonna steal my woman
no no that's the you're thinking about
oh you have Romeo the Romeo Romeo Romeo
the romancer yeah what do you think of
this great Romeo he's awesome man you
love him yeah it's hysterical this
[ __ ] guy yeah this is Romeo in the
bat you can't see him that well
girls I met yeah this is November last
[ __ ]
Romeo's hitting on a girl
[Laughter]
it's a busy bar indirectly yes I know
you know he knows he knows the boyfriend
who's the fat [ __ ] that was talking
about you when you walked out like like
you were the girl was she a friend of
yours or did you not know her and she
told you the guy was talking about you
there's one you had of your fat [ __ ] at
the bar who the owner no no no no no
which one is that we have looks like the
video the fat [ __ ] of Grizzlies bar yeah
okay see the guy with the jet shirt he's
the owner he he let me just tell you
real quick yeah
there were times I wasn't at this bar
and Romeo was and he was listening to
him degrade the [ __ ] work is that he
was a nasty bastard so were you a red
leaves a [ __ ] bully so he had caught
after the oh by the way after this
happened he called me much later that
night and he's trying to you know
wheezing me over to calm me down I said
let me ask you a question bro if you
sincere and you're in your apologizes
that would that girl you with when she
was whispering you she's what did she
say to you he goes in all Aziz she's
like lighten up your being kind of tough
on him huh Mike didn't want you [ __ ]
listen to her I said you doing it to her
and he goes whoa
I'm telling you apologize and I leave it
on you and I knew that what he was
nothing like I never called him back
what did he say about you you say he
says things about you just did you know
that the same guy thought oh I got him
good he made a comment and now he's
overweight I says cheese I know I let
him have his moment everyone's laughing
and the bartender look kind of like
Christie Brinkley and she was loving the
be nice she was shaking a drink and he
won't explain goes oh I like how you
shake that yeah you don't [ __ ] do
that to your work is they didn't make
money so so we're not when this was
going on you you're gonna see if pain
good no yeah you're gonna see a pain
quickly and she's the bartender and
you're gonna see quickly she's given so
many drinking she's like she was loving
cuz I was ripping the [ __ ] out of she
get it so he said something I remember
what it was and they're kind of laughing
you know Mike yeah I'm like wow jeez
that's funny
I knew Shamu could do a lot of tricks
but I didn't know it could talk to was
wrong
I had a black feminist and an overweight
Spanish for an argue and this was
hilarious not a shock is it the blade of
this bag you look like a zebra without
the Y Shrike
so the guy pause and you look like a
elephant without a truck dude this is
about six years ago people I know you
you are you alone the guy who isn't one
there you know when there's all this
gorgeous women on the plane you can't
get one it's like throw it's like
throwing the diamonds they're gonna
school the blues and you ain't snag on
it three hours what the [ __ ] if you say
like not even this is a fairly large
platform how would you not sell yourself
like a product boat like what would you
tell a woman that you have to offer
like like the same thing I tell
everybody else you know I I basically
just stop being so superficial I've told
women that the first thing that sees
your face that's the most important
thing and then of course she's gotta
have some kind of a nice chance that's
just my preference but and if you're oh
if you're 60 pounds overweight I don't
care I'm about 30 classes there yeah and
and and a personality and things in
common that you need that and some of
these women that have didn't want to go
back out with me because I'm sure and
they weren't even much taller than me
they were heavier than me I'm like who
the [ __ ] are you you ain't no but
doesn't this go bottle no this doesn't
isn't that a bit of a devil
standard if you're saying you know you
really we have to get along we have to
have a lot in common but you should have
a chest
if a woman responds by saying yeah we
have taken along and you should it helps
you should be five and a half feet tall
or more like you can't really get upset
by that can you know from that
standpoint you're right right you're
right yes yeah but if if I was willing
to they totally accept you even if they
weren't that big which there's been a
chance there yeah and they were having
the mean I'm not like oh you're not
you're not attracted enough to me I'm
like we'll look at you you [ __ ]
babble you look like a barrel right been
in the barrel yeah yeah dude come on
look at this guy are you sure why would
you here shape you could do why would
you know what sometimes the low-hanging
fruits a lot of fun but he is good
looking I I do hear though that like
like you know heavier women they they're
good because they weren't emotion when
they get it they want you know they want
to hold you hey we sorta dude seriously
like yeah what the [ __ ] we talking about
George kid yeah yeah this guy you know
he had his breast his breast onion
presentation you didn't try and a
rhinoplasty he had a rhinoplasty most
Amish thing the most obvious thing a
lobotomy another YouTube channel of a
man who we believe is you right and
you're with a woman of Asian descent and
you get in you're outside the car and
you go why don't you come back to my
house to fool around and she said no
thank you
and then you say okay well I'm gonna get
in the car I'll let you in it's a whole
story and you get in the car and you
drive away from
a very very nasty [ __ ]
tell me yeah what happening online and
then she was like not gonna go out me
because of my height she's 5-1 right so
then she finally I piss this is like I
was your height for the record five feet
so now this is 11 o'clock at night
before the date the next morning right
so she's so adamant she's a car will
make she lived in Flushing and I lived
in in Medford ah that's a far ride like
an hour so she's like Ari will be here
at 11:00 now I'll be waiting okay fine I
I left the house around 9:30 texture on
the way text and then nothing I get out
to the house and I got early I got there
at 20 to 11 I was early and I memory was
hot that day I was dressed up and [ __ ]
she didn't get in touch me to like 20
after 11 I'm like she just woke up and
then now it's 11:45 okay I sorry now I
do makeup she texts me on my sandwiches
yeah yeah I do makeup right guy she
comes out to the car how are you I says
I swear to god this is what I said
though I said are you [ __ ] kidding me
I just getting a [ __ ] call we're
going to dinner that's what I said to
her that's what I was yeah cold [ __ ]
man write this in the morning or at
night yeah the next morning I love the
clock in the morning on Saturday so
Sudan if I remember you had like a shirt
and tile
yeah I was just really well so then we
went to dinner and all that engine no I
went home and then she slowly starts
asking for money and then she begins to
get to convince me she's from planet
Pluto Wow
yeah I mean I have she was born on
planet Pluto she really said oh she's a
[ __ ] winning this one so I'm like I'm
right and I'm like I'm laughing it off
like I think she's trying to [ __ ] me and
she's like I'm dead serious
I have assets there I'm like do you
realize that's negative four degrees
there a dead fish couldn't live there oh
well I'm from much too cold yeah yeah
dead fish can't live anywhere no right
so and she's like she's done she's
trying to pull over this thing on me
about well I need you to look up a
rocket ship ride to me I'm like okay I'm
gonna [ __ ] with this girl so good okay
so I gave it like a day or two and I'm
like you're in luck I have a friend that
works at NASA I'm like I'm gonna get you
your ticket but it's gonna take a little
while it's gonna cost me seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars that's where that
so I picked her up the second time now
no so what happened no man she says were
you trying to get her to maybe give you
some sex in exchange for rockets or no
no not at all I wanted to see how much
of
[ __ ] gold ago she was soaked the
first date ended I and we stopped
talking cuz she was a [ __ ] I met this
other girl from Queens
then in January we broke up for a week I
call this [ __ ] back I see that's when I
picked her up at Flushing took her out
to Bay Shore to eat I want to go home
man it's calm I says we just agreed
we're gonna hang out all day I took you
out here for an hour to eat
I go no we're gonna go out to Pat row
now to have a beer and I'm playing this
to take her out even farther away from
my home right go to the paw I'm like I
got to think of something I gotta go to
the bathroom come back now we're walking
out now she's convinced that I'm gonna
be having her heard things being mailed
aha and it cost me so now I have my
hands in my coat pockets
awesome she puts her on she calls me
Harnam I look at this right right so
that's when it takes over I'm like you
[ __ ] greedy [ __ ] and that's why she
got what she got so he literally were
trying to go out there and this is why I
like you you wanted to have sex with a
girl who believes she was from Pluto yes
I know the girlfriend she forgot the
name you know you guys should smoke a
few this of our planet is it Earth is
that they she forgot the name of up I
thought I don't even know how it came
about and I was like you kidding Ryan
she's like are you serious I'm like did
your parents pay together you [ __ ]
graduate high school right maybe I guess
probably she's just a bench no I didn't
know I don't think so
I'm gonna have it how old was she she
was 19 years but this one I mean I mean
she said a lot of she was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] always but she was the time you
always [ __ ] never thank you
just a cool [ __ ] entitled entitled yeah
oh yeah oh yeah you know the ones that
don't have a pissin I've noticed think
the world [ __ ] owes him everything
right right and they don't even try him
no no now let me ask you this go to
college get the [ __ ] out then try yeah
you did
I did it all I've been knocked down so
many [ __ ] times but you get back up
damn straight I know when you report
report or how long did you do that a
couple of years maybe three I couldn't
live on it because what happened was is
that now too when you sue somebody you
know you you know it you either take the
settlement where you're not gonna get as
much but you're guaranteed right but if
you go you know double or whatever it's
gonna go longer you may win a big thing
but you're not guaranteed it so since
they
settle there's no need for deposition so
that cuts the amount of work down there
was a company Mineo that I closed down
they used to get like a thousand a month
they were down like four hundred yeah so
you couldn't survive as a Freeland I
took the test again in the courts but I
never got caught do you ask what I never
got called do you feel like there are
times in life when you maybe take out
your anger on people that don't deserve
it yeah no I'll admit that I do if I'm
gonna ban what everybody does but you
want to apologize yeah for that I do
yeah but but for the antagonistic smart
I don't go for that [ __ ] no more
I [ __ ] hate it so you have I get
embarrassed when as a lot of people
around she's doing I just I get in bear
who's think though you gave the do you
think day like Sam said do you think
that they got a bit of the wrath that
was built up before like you think you
haven't seen the vago video at all no I
don't ya know I have I have why should I
do you think when you watched it and you
saw like well there's a guy who's
justified in his anger that what you
thought yeah I says do you justify my
Napoleon complex now like that no one
said a [ __ ] word yeah yeah no I mean
I didn't I didn't from the video but you
know talking to you maybe a little bit
more clear but from the video I don't
know if it was wholly justified we don't
I understand that you know I apologize
for everybody I mean you're scared of
nothing that they didn't deserve that
but it's just you got to understand me
too but then I couldn't [ __ ] breathe
so do you know so have you come back to
apologize - no I haven't gone there yet
I think you will i it's up to the boss
over here I'm not going in there myself
like I said they could trap me right
right right I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're gonna do
I'm not trust me and if that happens
this whole thing shot with my boss I'm
not gonna risk going to jail for
trespassing really [ __ ] knows what they
gonna probably ask you I don't think
they would arrest you I'm not trusting
it I'm leaving up to the boy I'm not
[ __ ] trust in these people you
consider yourself a prophet yes yes I do
how so everything we talked about okay
I'm gonna change people's [ __ ] minds
on dead you are tells me yeah I said if
I take a bullet like JFK didn't Lennon
and Martin so I saw bit no I'm not gonna
change my mind
I'll speak the truth I don't get [ __ ]
I think somebody would want to like you
that those guys got cut down because
their messages were cut short cuz it
wanted [ __ ] peace give me a break is
that what you want peace yeah everybody
make money and little tons of love stop
fighting stop fighting in the bar
it shit's crazy stop trying so hard to
be a ha oh yeah you're hot
now if you're hot and you have you can
get anybody you want why are you
miserable for it makes sense to you it
doesn't make sense to me me are you
afraid to get it why not
I'm afraid somebody would want to cut
you down for your message not at all I
would think that anybody that did that
would all due respect you're a fool
right a for that means you're the devil
you're a fool
have you talked to your friend in the
7-eleven us what your height was when
you called and then you call them I've
been back there but you know we just
kind of slowly you know yeah but we
haven't like this and right right so
what does he do when you walk in now
just go hey how much you weigh but it's
it slowly if you don't realize just
being repaired right cuz it didn't it
didn't Rupp to the extent that the bagel
thing a couple of people told me you
know you know some family must maybe
shouldn't go in there's just no I'm not
going right now I'm not gonna [ __ ]
lose my freedom for that [ __ ] is it
frustrating when somebody asks you how
tall you are and then you call the
police and the police tell you I can't
do anything again
like like for example the other night we
were at a bar it was a ton of fights
yeah and it was six cop coasting into a
[ __ ] thing - guys were laying in the
street just one guy had him in a
headlock and the other guy was hitting
him and they didn't do nothing right why
we paying all this money and like I
don't get it man
what would you have liked I remember
that time the cops came in the at
7-eleven video and you were kind of
annoyed they weren't doing anything what
did you want them to do when they came
there what did you what did you want the
police to do give him a citation or
something for harassment no man put his
hands on me I'm a [ __ ] citation right
for harassing you because I'm sorry
getting tickets for this speeding that
marijuana give him a [ __ ] come on you
gotten tickets for speeding in marijuana
yeah the only one speeding ticket but
yeah yeah but you can have marijuana at
the time like you were sweet it was it
wasn't like you were high no I know no I
was trying I was I was in a rush to get
some Moya's oh yeah women want to meet
you how can they me because I mean
obviously now that you have this
newfound fame there's a lot of people
I'm always the patient's yeah were you
telling I watched the interview you did
with News 12 and you were saying that
you've made the conscious choice to live
in your van yes I walked out from the
landlord and it was something new I
wanted to try it's not gonna be forever
it's
been a little over two months and but
but and everybody's like has idea her
like it's so horrible it's not I've
haven't the time I've never been happier
as far as my how my life's going so what
are you in that bagel store yeah that
was you at your happiest point in life
what do you mean oh you mean oh you
don't mean me flipping out you mean at
that point that yeah yeah I mean
everyday it's like I'll be back I'm
going to do that I mean I know everybody
in town were like a clicking a family
and yeah I mean I'm not gonna say just
in case oh well there was certain I
can't reveal that all right don't talk
about that off camera doesn't get hot at
night without because it's got it's a
it's a it's a 2008 talent country
Chrysler so she got tend to win it so it
diffuses the light
have you gotten laid that VIN yeah you
have you've had sex in the van yes my
god van sex my god I have a picture of
who she's not my phone you do really
she's pretty hot are you seeing her
regular showing of my show I have a
bunch of who I've had sexual they're
pretty good look at Sonya do you send I
mean cuz you're you're you're living in
the digital age you know I mean
obviously meeting women online do you
send pictures of your genitals a lot of
people no no no Jim you do yes a lot
lots of yeah no one's ever threatened
like sexual harass and take you to court
or no I mean I'll lead off with that day
nuts do they threaten you no oh my god
I'm doing this now there's a dirty
discussion like I don't use enough I'm
just talking to somebody go what time do
you need me I still don't ever trust
anybody because that could be a trap
well but it's in text if it wasn't
married right Jim listen I once I got in
trouble one time someone asked me a girl
is dating asked me what time do you want
to meet and I wrapped a watch around my
penis and I said dick o'clock that's
right yeah and she started claiming
sexual harassment can you believe that
as well talking about that I mean yeah
these chicks huh you know you can't
trust him Jim is one already and I've
heard this from tons of people
I meant so you've never sent it a photo
right I like that you don't know what
about like ass shots or anything no I
never shared up all do you get them from
them yeah you ask euro send your breast
pictures know all the shit's pouring in
on even ask for any of the [ __ ] but you
get
they're telling me all these naked
photos now I'm like I didn't ask for
this [ __ ] nice that just thrown around
like frisbees remember how many more
excuse me that's mine but he's mine
right we did the stand up for my pock
excuse it was his mind so you want to
you want to just find a nice curry
you're not looking a [ __ ] bunch of
different girls you want to find a nice
girl until I find her I want I want to
[ __ ] his men come on I mean what am I
gonna do be syllabus until I never find
her I wanted to be syllabus hey bunny
what do you want to do hello what do you
do to us - to it did it goes both ways
lazy and there are a lot of shitty men I
give you that I think I know here's the
thing about your bad behavior you can
justify it thank you
right yes it's not it's not unreasonable
yeah I'm not just some homeless blue
nitaac that's got severe mental problems
no we are proud of you Ven
Yeah right I go to the gym I shower I
clean my clothes I'm gonna get where Lee
Beom where do you where do you shower I
belong to a gym in the gym perfect yeah
and when it's open all day so you can go
exactly and you got a laundromat to wash
your clothes of course I vacuum a van
out I spray cleaning yeah of course you
Febreze in there I'm sure yeah of course
man yeah where do you where where do you
defecate [ __ ] oh if I find a bathroom or
wherever the gyms have it right if I'm
fishing out they have bathrooms down at
the marina
[ __ ] it no no never go in a bush or
something if you had to go real bad in
the past year I mean if it's know if
it's late and I've your night fishing
right like if you're like it's Smith
Point Bridge and there's there's a trail
that goes down and you go under the
bridge and you fish here but you can
literally go sit in the yoga class and I
know it's gross but if you get you got
to do bathrooms around that that's the
[ __ ] area that you have to yeah I
had no choice yeah I hate shooting
outdoors it is it's gross but what the
[ __ ] are you doing and I do you gotta
get it I have to do it man paper with
you but yeah yeah yeah yeah you have to
do with all the fish might make you fish
all I need to sell them or I flame and
given the French
nice yeah if you hate not being on the
store food in the van or do you have a
cool I have a cool yeah when I said one
guy trade it for marijuana he gives me
bags marijuana that's very old-school
you'll catch your own food and trade it
for some partnership or the ancient days
when all the different cultures would
would pass through the Great Wall of
China they exchange goods right and
you've seen you you you're big into the
great so see ancient times the Roman
Emperor they've been doing that show you
what you do you oh you went to the Great
Wall of trying to Jack sure in the wall
itself I want to but I hate the floor
but I would love do that Italy and very
vague Oh UN Tunisia Indonesian sorry I
was yeah I would love to retirement San
Diego never been in my dad hasn't he
says it's got one most beautiful sunsets
there but how close are you retirement
do you think no ways near you want to
retire to San Diego either that maybe
Cape Cod well if you if you live in a
van around by the river yeah why don't
you just why don't you just drive the
van to Cape Cod now be you could like it
what things are happening you know so
I'm not when it's time where I know I
can I will I sure you gotta be at the
moment what you got to be around show
business a tough boss here so you have a
manager you're trying to capitalize on
the on the show business aspect of this
what are your goals in the entertainment
industry
I'll grab any kind of work like
commercials ad libbing boxing matches I
would love down my own talk show rock
videos anything talk show now what who
do would you want to interview on a talk
show
it's endless bro yeah like what kind of
a talk show would you want to do a
monologue and then and then ask
questions or sketches or like I want to
do like what cost and would do when
Ronnie would come on make him piss his
[ __ ] pants [ __ ] like that
yeah but except for you it'd be you and
Romeo co-hosts Romeo's at Carlos do you
hear me imitate the Iron Sheik more than
that would be great I [ __ ] us and make
it over that [ __ ] precise [ __ ] Oh
Colin he's still my dog dog barking
Jesus
[Music]
[ __ ] sauce and makeup over a
breakfast back [ __ ] you I'm the one with
the damage talk who else do you do you
yeah you know Joe Pesci oppression
because somebody else compares you to
passion yeah I'm trying to think of one
of the Joe Donald Rickles was a [ __ ]
God in the industry Don Rickles on it I
can't imitate him he's won a few I can't
but you sound like he thinks this is
funny huh the [ __ ] you lookin at yep you
believe this prick hey yes made a
Christian is Creole I just you know
you're 7,000 I charge them so you make
your friends laugh I love making people
I love people are coming up the boss
saying I'm changing in life and I and
that's why I love my fans I'll never
charge them a dollar for because the
industry I'm sure will take care of that
sure I'm not gonna charge my fans any
money to ever me me you don't have to
ask me for a photo it's a nonsense what
if it is a convention I'm sure they have
convention where you going people do
anything meet you yeah you stand in a
convention at the table that's something
that will be left up to the people that
handle the business that's not I I mean
I was talking to manager right now and
say like let's charge for some pictures
I wouldn't but that's up to him as far
as photos and all that [ __ ] now I'm not
charging if somebody throws a one guy
did this at the bar he threw me 20 bucks
and and I refused and he was nachos is
alright but that but other than that I
know I don't expect now you'll just take
a picture because you people I love it
yeah love it mind if I can smart money
that can get through what I went through
hell yeah man now I'm certain I've heard
you have a celebrity boxing match coming
up in September when the Hydra kids hide
your wife guy from YouTube right antoine
dodson yeah I was just seeing the police
action he needs a guy who says like hide
your kids hide your wife he kind of
looks like a heroin version of RuPaul
the are you transferring the
trash-talking that's good stuff I don't
just mean us I'm not even trying to be
rude you got to talk to you well into
the building yeah
yes yes okay that's what he looks like
are you gonna kick the [ __ ] out of him
do you think I don't know if I'm allowed
to feel the reveal details I just don't
find it can you fight have you ever have
you flying I haven't ever taken boxing
but yeah I mean I could I could do
pretty good for myself
yeah sure are you training no I don't
need to train is this a fixed fight no
I'm sure it's not a fixed fight no ask
Anthony I don't know if I should know
it's not a fixed fight it's a real fight
so what do you think you should train
muscle mania is not fixed
you wanna train oh my god I just want to
smack with means a god damn ugly
no offense so he's gonna sue script it
in there to win this one do we know yet
you want me to spoil that it's just boy
allowed you I mean I want to know ask
him who's gonna win you know I would
think that they'll probably script our
friend here to win I think Antoine is a
little bit yesterday's news Chris the
bagel guy is today's news right I think
I think the fix is in for Chris the
bagel guy that's what I think where are
you doing this fuzzy garden where is it
again no Anthony it's somebody's garden
I think it's in Jersey to Atlantic City
oh it isn't wait Chris is giving you
he's giving you the information yeah
landing city so yeah subscribe to a
Facebook but you know all that stuff
Instagram Bay Chris bagel boss Morgan
and yeah I'm finding uh in Atlantic City
September 7th at the showboat hotel all
right so what's your place you know to
act celebrity boxing one on Instagram
with your Instagram Chris yeah no no I
want to can plug it you should plug it
what do you mean plug it it doesn't have
a plug to plug in Jimmy
it's hold on Chris bagel boss Morgan an
Instagram hope you want to follow you
course Morgan just write it I know I'm
not saying I'm not a stupid [ __ ] I'm
stupid it doesn't say on YouTube Chris
bagel boss my real bagel boss here's
your thing mister now let me ask you
this Chris you're putting a lot of trust
into this manager how do you know that
he's not and no offense to your manager
of course but yeah how do you know based
on history he's not another person who's
gonna take money from you because first
of all were in contract and yeah the
last few days the work they've put in
I see the they were saying things that
that that he went out of his way above
and beyond to you know do things and all
that kind of stuff that I didn't know
and then it constantly shown me the
numbers it I trust these guys yeah yeah
and plus the fact that that things have
been taken care of where I didn't have
to go my own wall and it's just like
home crap they're looking to make money
with you but it's a valuable investment
but not everybody thought nobody's ever
done that so I mean listen if nobody
have a Forks $1 out that's sketchy but
there are they taken they're already
proving that they're in this from you oh
yeah yeah they're like the best I've
ever seen I trust I mean what's it like
to be on that on that a that list of the
top viral stars of the famous yeah viral
stars you're gonna be I mean you're
Chocolate Rain over here I don't even
know what to say to be honest but except
thank all my fans and all the guys that
did the work to put me on that platform
how do you feel about all the negative
response though a lot of doesn't make me
want of you I don't give a [ __ ] you know
it doesn't affect me that much anymore
ever since I got hooked up with this
opportunity right because you're making
my how are you gonna do is follow up
because people always want to follow up
they always want to guard what he got
now for us what do you got for us now so
what are you gonna do next well I'm
always writing
I used to write like comedy songs on
real songs like we at a land so I can
throw it's a comedy song you wrote I
wrote a bunch but they were mostly
sexually explicit but was okay that's
not the only thing I can
remember the one line is this it was
about instead of the Billy Joel bigshot
it was about Obama what are you gonna be
a big [ __ ] like that you're not afraid
to get political either no no not in
halls or instead of do you really want
to hurt me from from boys do you really
think the [ __ ] songs I had like eight
of them stay behind for years and I
threw them out hey I know and I was
gonna be here today I would have kept
the [ __ ] you thrown out for I just it's
at my closet for years and it just
collected though maybe
did you sing them or just write them I
just roll no no no they were all typed
out but I just [ __ ] didn't keep them
let me ask you this how often do you
find yourself falling into a fit of rage
not as much as I used to especially now
I don't even at the time which is great
because we're working but I mean and you
know only away from that which is like
let's start with I mean starting from
the bagel boss incident and I'll say and
before how often is not as much are we
talking about on and off you know like
not every day you know but on a couple
times a week
yeah there were reasons why you're not
starting the problems no no no no no no
like there'll be people that go up to
you to your stuff at the marina and just
touch your [ __ ] right and and then you
know and it's like you didn't pay for
this and they they wait to steal your
[ __ ] what'd you get on camera starts to
hit on cameo yeah that's what you should
do on the [ __ ] bagel boy sky yell at
you on cameo yeah we'll give a nice
message whatever you want happy birthday
you flat titted idiots right over the
right message that's fine we all have to
tell jokes just joke it is not meant
Fame race it's just funny showing up so
I'm not out to offend anybody or just
making sure it's just jokes I'm trying
to think of the two but okay so um are
you sure this is okay I can open for him
okay how will black people in slinkys
alike they're both useless but therefore
watch for states that's a rough one
Chris I would agree
that one oh yeah but it's not remember
the truly tasteless jokes that came out
not that's where I got it from there
were books published I love that joke
this is there was just a documentary
about but I won't tell anymore erase the
stuff these days because what looks I've
taken tons of short jokes oh sure taking
me not you meaning the public but I
won't mention times have changed and
people really mad that stuff now I mean
this from a guy who gets into fights
with a store clerk so a couple times a
week over short jokes I would think that
you'd be sensitive well I get bothered
by things you know you have no place but
you don't want to this day and age
people get in trouble for that stuff
right and you don't want to shoot
yourself in the foot you get all this
Fame going on in this career is in close
range
yeah right but everything is just joking
fun it's nothing's meant to look I don't
turn into that kind of a person unless
there's a reason right I don't I don't
start [ __ ] with anybody in let me ask
you this what do you say to these people
they kind of get on your case a little
bit and they you would say the people
that would say hey Chris if everyone's
the problem that means you're the
problem
yeah I know well that's another method
of their what's called a for psychology
I see now you don't want people to get
the wrong idea because you told a joke
like this so what would you say to
people who said hey this guy is a racist
or this guy not I black friends that
hang out at the marina I'm not racist
for God's sakes man come I couldn't I
think of at least 7 I just popped the
man that I used to see every day when I
was unemployed fishing there so your
perception is [ __ ] not you Yeah
right
how much more really woman a bit yeah
you don't want people to misinterpret of
Joffe this guy you still have a product
I don't know what to tell you it's
called a scotoma it's a block in your
head that I can't change your thinking
you know it's interest on my problem
right it does it doesn't seem like a lot
of times your philosophy is here's my
statement right and if you would like to
disagree or question it right you're an
idiot
no not that they're an idiot but if
they're if they question it that's fine
if they if I come across as ambiguous
but but but if I'm telling you it's a
joke and you still get mad then you got
a [ __ ] problem
you don't like whom people judge you
like you don't mind if they disagree
with you but if when someone starts
judge
yeah like people people people will joke
with me a lot but and then there and
then it starts to get out of hand
and they don't say that joke and I'm
telling you I'm joking if you still have
a prominent yeah yeah that's not my
problem I'm not gonna sit even trying to
convince enough [ __ ] to worry about hey
remember when Romeo was in there just
kind of dancing in the back like that
try can you pull up these about an inch
to love me he's got the biggest [ __ ]
swag Oh take advantage of you you look
tickled watch watch watch watch he's
gonna go the other table full of people
didn't see matter today didn't get it
did you get it I was so focused on man I
stared round right we said that's their
problem
exactly yeah he looked so happy that was
so around [ __ ] phony money yeah is
that the same guy that did the [ __ ]
job no that was wrong me the puppet I
was Jose I couldn't see because he had a
hat on him right yeah we thought it was
the same he's not the same so what's
next for for Chris Morgan working people
keep up with you Chris his friend Jose
story
stop stop stop before you play this he
he told me story line I know he used to
hang down and I didn't know him but he
knew me he told me his story I didn't
know this he goes he goes I had passed
out in my Colin day with a blunt hanging
out burning in out of the window he goes
this is how he wanted to get to know me
he's like the cops went by looked at me
they looked at each other when he goes
it's crazy [ __ ] I'm like are you serious
they didn't say nothing to his Bernier's
yeah you [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] basically
show you with you kind of you just
sitting there's not shown the hand out
of your
yeah I did probably looking up I got the
20 tickets like [ __ ] up guys areas
leaning into his here your living room
window and he's like and he's got his
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
did he write that or he doesn't this
isn't in problem really yo you know what
he did before this no here whoops that
amazed she we know he'll put that up
yeah jail yeah he pulls up and he'll
just sit then he whips out a megaphone
and he was [ __ ] with people there he
was and then another friend of mine
there was a couple hot chick on the
beach I said yo go down there roll the
windows had a blast porno music and he
and they will they started laughing
another time you know that many uses of
the word [ __ ] you know that
no yeah you know that right oh yeah I'm
like blast out at the beach people like
one guy comes up it goes what radio
stations I just not right now it's
[ __ ] you too
we started pulling the most erotic [ __ ]
down at that marina like like what two
weeks before we met Anthony and all that
this is not well how we will live in you
guys it's a party everyone yeah just I
miss a ton of my friends tons of them
doing wacky [ __ ] like this highs and
lows freaking hilarious man highs and
lows yeah and this is the way the best
way that if I don't have a woman in deal
with depressions this is what I do every
you need a reality show thank you
you've been saying that right well some
when I posted that how Kaleo think the
guy would when he told me about his
business he posed a heap I owe it might
have been so honest he said that months
ago he this guy needs a reality show
yeah and now you said yeah hey that's
[ __ ] ironic problems that interesting
absolutely it's um one of those things
you should work on next I have no idea
how to pull it off like I said it's up
to him I have no connections that
happened he does oh I have the talent I
can bring it that's obvious that's out
of my ass one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM Adam